تيك توك مخاوفه الامن القومي ملف متجدد
للولايات المتحده دفعها للمطالبه مرارا
بحذف منصه الامر الذي فتح باب التساؤل حول
الاسباب
[موسيقى]
حول الوصول لبيانات المستخدمين من داخل
اعلى هرم السلطه في بكين لكن بعض الخبراء
يعتبرونها مخاوف ومبالغه فيها فالعديد من
الجهه يمكنه الوصول للبيانات
تقوم الشركات باستمرار بجمع كميات هائله
من البيانات سواء كانت شركات امريكيه او
اجنبيه
[موسيقى]
الهاجس الابرز كان مخاوف التجسس خاصه على
حسابات بعض القاده السياسيين او المعارضين
وهو الامر نفسه الذي ينطبق على بقيه
التطبيقات
قد نقوم بتثبيت الاصدار الصيني من بيجاسوس
على هواتفنا ذكيه اعتقد ان هذا هو ما يقلق
الحكومه في الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
من المخاطر المرتبطه بتك توك امكانيه قيام
السلطات الصينيه بمراقبه محتوى معين
لتماشى مع سياستها بالتالي تشكيل المشهد
العام للمستخدمين وفقا للسيناريو الذي
يرضيها وهو متن في تيك توك القيام به
[موسيقى]
امر اخر يسرق واشنطن اذا اتتك هو احتمال
تعديل المحتوى التوجه السياسي للتاثير على
الراي وتعطي للعمليه الديمقراطيه على غرار
الحمله الروسيه قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه
عام 2016
وردت المناصه على تلك الثغرات بتدابير
للتحقق من الحسابات الحكوميه والسياسيه
[موسيقى]
يبقى العداء التاريخي وبين النسر الامريكي
والتنين الصينيه بعض الخبراء يشككون في
قدرته تيك توك طمنتها مخاوي في واشنطن
التي نبذت المنصه من حيث المبدا بسبب
علاقتها مع الصين روان حمزه العربيه